welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and just recently the official
poster for the new Super Mario Brothers
movie was released and it is not only
gorgeous but it is packed with details
you know me I love you some good details
hey Anna from the future here so after I
filmed this two new posters dropped
which is very own brand luckily your
girl did her due diligence in my
previous breakdown so if you want to see
my assessment of the obstacle course in
the background of the first poster I
would direct you to this video and if
you want to see my detailed assessment
of Luigi's surroundings in the second
poster my tie direct you to this video
and this video a couple new things to
point out in these two would be Mario's
classic jumping pose in the first one
and then in the second one we can see
new details of the hot air balloon
actually being in the shape of the shy
guy head which is hilarious and some
bats in the sky originally from Super
Mario Galaxy now before you leave a
comment hold on scroll back up keep
watching swoops originally known as
swoopers are bat type characters in many
Mario games but the Prima official game
guide of Super Mario Galaxy CN Galaxy 2
differentiate bats from swoops so what
these will be called in the movie I'm
not sure yet but I'll go with the guide
for now thank you for coming to my TED
Talk and now I'm still going to be
talking about the official official
posters like this you'll see all right
let's get back to the video sorry taking
care of yourself is important so good
thing geology makes it easy to do
geology is a 16 time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognized in hypebeast birdie Men's
Health Esquire and ask men grooming
Awards with over 6 000 5 Star reviews
just take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz in geology will create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
customized just for you with ingredients
that are dermatologist tested proven to
work and personalized for your needs for
Hair Care geology's got strengthening
shampoo and conditioner and co-wash
which will transform your routine and
deliver the best hair of your life it
extends the time between washes and
replaces the need for so many products
so you wash your hair less and save
money more they also offer body washes
and deodorants that are free of harsh
ingredients and smell great for skincare
they have you covered from all angles
fight acne reduce oiliness prevent
wrinkles combat darker puffy under eyes
have smoother hydrated skin and Target
signs of aging their daily personalized
skincare routine comes with two face
washes morning face cream retinol night
cream and eye cream and right now for a
limited time you can get a five piece
trial set for only 15 if you use the
code rockstar70 at checkout that's over
50 dollars a product for just 15 on top
of that you can take an additional 30
bonus offer on one of their brand new
skin hair and body products of your
choice when you add it to your trial to
get started just click the link in the
description but before we look at that
poster I actually want to look at a past
poster that was released because there's
something that I can't seem to let go of
in this poster featuring Mario there's a
toad off to the right that clearly has a
very distinct design that separates them
from the other toads but who is it I
have three guests as to who this mystery
toad is my first guess is that this is
chanterelle the singer that performs at
Club 64 and Paper Mario chanterelle's
name was called out in a clip from the
movie
and like I previously said in a
breakdown they're the same purple color
as chanterelle was in Paper Mario though
it would make sense that a toad featured
in the trailer might be featured in the
poster as well considering the singer
also wears a dress and long Opera gloves
I wouldn't be surprised if it were the
same character and maybe casually they
wear the same street attire as all the
other toad but when they have a
performance they get decked out in
fancier attire my second guess however
is that they could possibly be the owner
of one or more of the tool slash weapon
shops that we see scattered about toad
town and that they're wearing a
protective apron and leather Gauntlet
gloves or welding gloves of some type
this might seem like a bit of a stretch
but like I said in that previous
breakdown there are four of those shops
that we see in that one clip not only
that but if we jump to the other poster
for a second there's one featured right
there in the poster possibly two if
every shop with a hammer is also a tool
or weapon shop like we see in the movie
clip and who's making their way towards
that shop a purple toad I'm not saying
I'm just saying so it's possible this
toad might be a character who helps
Mario prepare for his journey by loading
him up with tools or weapon my last is
that this might be an original character
who serves as a new romantic interest
for toad they sort of look like they're
clasping their hands in a very like my
hero kind of way and so maybe while
Peach roots on Mario even though she
very clearly joins in the action too
maybe this toad is one of Peach's toads
in Waiting who is rooting on toad as he
joins Mario in his journey in wishing
him safe travels so he can come back
home and smooch to be honest this is
probably the least likely Theory but I'm
working with what I got here anyway this
toad has gotten their screen time so on
to the official poster this poster is
beautiful it's a floating head style
poster much like Avengers end game or
Ant-Man quantumania but the Symmetry and
the colors and everything are just so
good and it contains a shocking number
of details in the background starting in
the top right corner we have rainbow
roads spiraling through the sky complete
with Racers on the track we did see
Rainbow Road in one of the trailers but
this is the first time we're seeing it
surrounded by stars like how we're used
to seeing it in the games also above
rainbow road is the same Aurora Borealis
that we saw in the ice kingdom in the
original teaser trailer moving over to
the left side we see Bowser's paratroopa
swarming in and there's one in
particular in the foreground that stands
out we have yet to get a name for this
character but it was them who we more
than likely saw in the teaser when
Bowser's Army is assembled it's hard to
tell if this is meant to be the same
Koopa that was in this later shot since
the second one doesn't seem to have
wings but if they're the same Koopa it
seems like there might only be one blue
shell poop in Bowser's troop and since
they are one of the eight featured
characters in the poster that leads me
to believe they're going to be playing a
larger role than the other troop members
maybe a general of sorts for the army of
Koopa troopas what's also interesting
about this character is it's the first
time we've ever seen the potential
source of a spiny shell popular in Mario
Kart games it's always been a bit of a
mystery as to where the blue Spike
shells come from since well there have
been blue shells in past Mario games
Koopas with blue shells are extremely
rare and none of them have ever had
spikes on their shells now there are
enemies called sky blue spinies that are
in Paper Mario the Thousand Year Door
but since all the other shells you throw
in Mario Kart come from these types of
Koopas it seems like this is going to be
the Canon answer as to where spiny
shells come from add on the fact that in
several of the Mario Kart games the
spiny shell has
much like a paratroopa and I'd say this
is now the official origin and since
there's Mario karting in the movie I
wonder if we'll see a first place
blowout caused by this little guy but
moving on down at the bottom left we see
Bowser's massive Army lined up and ready
for battle much like in the teaser and
then bottom right we have a view of toad
town with its own little details for one
these two toads are arguing for some
reason probably because this one wants
to trade the other for his very small
hat but they're not having it but these
very small hats are commodity in this
day and age but we can also see a pow
Block in the tool shop as well as a cake
feather which depending on the game
either allows a cart to jump like in
Mario Kart or gives Mario a cool yellow
cape he can fly around in like in Super
Mario World not as cool as a very small
hat but it's awesome I hope you enjoyed
exploring all those cool hidden details
in these posters and now if you'll
excuse me I need to go stare at my very
small hat collection until I don't feel
pain anymore until then you can follow
me on Twitter at it's annavanston and
follow And subscribe to new rockstars at
new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love bye
[Music]